[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
STUDENT PRESENTER:
Thank you, everybody.
I'm going to talk today
about the Confederated
Salish-Kootenai tribe, which
I'll refer to as CSKT, tribe's
compact with the state of
Montana, to which the US
government is also party.
This compact kind
of evolved over
the course of a few decades
and actually just started
to be implemented this year.
So we'll talk about
how they got there.
Just to start, this is Montana.
These are the various water
basins in the state of Montana.
This little area
in the corner here
is the Flathead reservation.
So it's actually a fairly
large chunk of land.
The water rights that
we're talking about today
really cover the entire region
of Northwest Montana, mostly
west of the Continental
Divide, but there
are some rights
that were affected
by the treaty that actually
are on the east side
of the Continental Divide.
So we're going to talk about
the history, the kind of way
that these water
rights came about,
some of the context
of the negotiations.
Talk a little bit about
the negotiation topics,
then where they ended up.
And even as I go
through the history,
I hope to explain, because some
of the disputed rights, a lot
of the questions go back to
the origins of those rights,
I hope to bring up some
of the different disputes
in the historical context
and also kind of begin
to shed light on the
present status of them
and how they came up with
the negotiations based
on that context.
So to quickly look a
little bit at the history,
the Treaty of Hellgate,
which is the treaty that
created the Flathead reservation
in Northwest Montana,
it's about a million
and a quarter acres,
was signed in 1855 by
representatives of the US
as well as the tribes that
were party to the treaty.
The treaty gave them
the rights to that land,
but it also included
an unusual line
which has become very
important that was not
included in any of
the other treaties
that the US
government negotiated
with the state of Montana.
This line is Article
III: "The exclusive right
of taking fish and
all the streams
running through or bordering
said reservation is further
secured to said Indians.
As also the right of taking
fish at all usual and accustomed
places in common with
citizens of the territory."
So this provision
maintained that the tribes
had the rights to
use water that passed
through some of the
lands that they conceded.
The part that says "the
right of taking fish
at all usual and
accustomed places."
This is the basis
of what have become
to be known as the tribe's
off reservation water rights.
And we'll talk
about what those are
and how those
became contentious.
As was often the case with
treaties of Native tribes,
the US government
violated the spirit
and the letter of
the Hellgate treaty
within a number of decades.
The kind of general
history that pertains
to all the Native American
tribes is in 1887,
the Dawes Act was passed, which
subdivided Native reservations
into individual allotments
and opened reservations
to settlement by whites.
In particular, the
Flathead reservation,
this kind of accelerated
after the Flathead Allotment
Act of 1954, provided for the
distribution and irrigation
of actually a few different
sizes of allotments
but predominantly
160 acre allotments
to Indian households.
And then the rest of the
acres that weren't given out
were considered surplus.
And those surplus
acres were available
to non-tribal members.
And so today actually most
Flathead reservation residents
are not tribal members.
And there are many, both public
and private non-tribal water
uses, including municipal uses.
For example, Polson,
Montana, which
is the county seat
of Lake County, which
is one of four counties that
enters into the Flathead
reservation, Polson, Montana is
the seat county of Lake Montana
and it's the largest town
in the Flathead reservation.
So I think it's just
important to recognize
the complexity of the land use.
The Flathead Indian
Irrigation Project
was a federally funded
irrigation system
that was developed over the
course of the first half
century, mostly in
the '20s and '30s.
And it's really a
really extensive network
of irrigable acres of canals,
laterals, distribution systems,
pumping stations,
storage reservoirs that
provides irrigation to all of
the land that was described
on the past slide, both
Native uses, Native users,
and municipal and
non-Native users,
particularly agricultural
users on the reservation who
are not members of the tribe.
So that's what you need
to know about that.
Oh yeah, and it's
important to note
that CSKT operates a
large portion of FIIP,
of the Flathead Indian
Irrigation Project,
and has since the '80s.
So water rights.
Like many western
states, Montana
adopted a "first in time,
first in right" doctrine
of prior appropriation.
And until 1973, most
rights in the state
were use rights,
which means they
were exercised when someone
basically took water
for a beneficial use.
Most of the time they
never filed those rights
with the county or the state.
And so many rights
have no paper record.
Rights often spanned
multiple counties.
And there'd be competing claims
to the same quantity of water.
I mean, this became
increasingly complex
because rights were also kept
in the county courthouses.
And so even if a
right was filed,
you had to go to every
county courthouse
to figure out if there
were competing rights.
So in 1972 when Montana adopted
a new state constitution
recognizing existing
water rights,
it also called upon
the state legislature
to quote, "establish a system
of centralized records for water
rights."
And that's the origin
of the dispute,
is the status of Indian rights
in the centralized record.
In 1973, Montana passed
the Water Use Act,
which mandated that the
Department of Natural Resources
and Conservation
permit new claims
and manage a record
of water rights.
And it established a system of
adjudicating pre-1973 claims.
This means that
all new claims had
to be filed with the
Department of Natural Resources
and Conservation.
And it began to create
a bureaucratic structure
for looking at all claims
filed or existing even if they
weren't filed prior to 1973.
In '79, the Senate Bill 76
established the Montana Water
Court, which was set up
initially on a 15 year term
limit, although it's still
around now 50 years later
and they're hoping to
have all the work done--
I believe the most recent
estimate I saw was by 2028.
But even that is questionable.
And established the
water court to adjudicate
all pre-1973 claims.
However, while this legislation
was under consideration,
both the US Department
of the Interior
and the tribes
expressed opposition
to having their water rights
adjudicated by a state court,
because they argue
that these water
rights, both the federal
water rights pertaining
to federal lands,
whether they're
national parks or Bureau
of Land Management lands,
and also the Native
water rights which
were held in trust
by the US government,
they argue that they were
not subject to state courts.
And many in Montana's
agricultural community
also opposed the
use of water courts
to determine Native rights,
because ranchers and others
both on the reservation and
off the reservation feared
that extensive tribal
claims would supersede
their historical rights
because of the "first in time"
doctrine.
In response, the legislature
amended the draft legislation
and established the Montana
Reserved Water Rights Compact
Commission, which negotiates
on the state's behalf.
The commission was also
initially authorized
for a limited
term, but that term
was extended and
extended and extended.
We'll talk about
where it ended up.
Just quickly, there are
two kinds of tribal rights
that pertain.
There are federally
reserved rights
that were set aside by the
federal government for use
by the Native tribe.
And these have a
priority date that's
equivalent to the date of
the reservation's creation.
So in the Flathead
reservation, it's 1855.
And they're governed by
what's called the Winters
Doctrine, which refers to the
Supreme Court doctrine that
said that when the US set aside
land for Indian reservation,
it implicitly reserved
adequate water for the tribes
to fulfill their livelihoods.
And so this is the
on-reservation rights
that we're talking about
that are federally reserved.
The Aboriginal rights are rights
that predate a reservation
and are explicitly recognized
in the treaty or statute that
created the reservation.
And these rights have a
different priority date
of time immemorial.
And time immemorial
means, I thought
that was an
interesting term, what
it means is time extended beyond
the reach of memory, record,
or tradition,
indefinitely ancient
beyond memory or record.
So these are the
off-reservation rights
that were subject to that
kind of the provision
in the original treaty
that I mentioned.
And two things to
note about this.
The Aboriginal rights almost by
definition because of the time
immemorial claim
would by definition
have an earlier priority
date than all other claims
in all other water rights in
Montana because of the time
immemorial date.
And something similar
has actually occurred,
although it's been more
disputed with the federally
reserved rights.
Given that the Flathead
reservation was not
open to homesteading by
non-tribal members until 1909,
the tribe has argued that
their on-reservation rights are
necessarily superior
or senior, sorry,
to all other
on-reservation rights,
regardless of whether they're
Aboriginal or reserve.
But this fact, which
has come to be accepted,
was not accepted at the time
by many non-tribal residents
of the reservation, especially
ranchers and other kind
of large irrigators as well as a
number of municipal governments
and Republican state legislators
who argued that this somehow
constituted an unconstitutional
taking under the US
Constitution, under the
Montana Constitution.
It's not worth getting
into it, but just
to say that there wasn't
agreement at the beginning that
was the fact.
Legislation that
I just discussed
set up the Montana State
Compact Commission.
And the Compact Commission
is a nine member commission
appointed to four year terms,
kind of in this makeup.
And it created this
really complex process
for getting an
agreement negotiated.
First there were
negotiations, and then
the full commission
once agreed upon
had to vote upon
the negotiations.
Then it had to go to the
Montana state legislature who
had to ratify it.
Then the tribal compact, so
on the left hand column now,
then had to go to
the US Congress.
And Congress, both the
Senate and the House,
had to ratify it.
The president had to sign it.
The tribe then had to
vote to approve it.
And it then needs a kind
of pro forma approval
by the Montana Water Court,
who issues the final decree,
entering the rights agreed
upon into the system
that the state now manages
according to the 1973
constitution.
So there's a huge
number of parties
who have to sign on to this.
At every step of
the way, there have
been roadblocks and
issues and renegotiations
as a result of the complexity
of this process and just
how many parties were apart.
So there are a couple of
other contextual things
that I want to bring
up, because I think
they're important
to understanding
the contentiousness
of the conversations
around the compact.
Three court cases that--
I'm going to try
to pronounce it.
Ciotti I, II, and III, I guess.
There were three
court cases that
were filed between 1996 and 2003
and argued before the Supreme
Court.
And actually the
last one was only
found during the
actual negotiations.
It was when the Supreme
Court made its ruling.
And it recognized
the distinction
between state appropriative
water rights and reserve water
rights.
And the ruling was that new
and amended water use permits
on the reservation had to show
that their proposed uses would
not, quote,
"unreasonably interfere
with a planned use for
which water has already
been reserved."
And what the Supreme
Court said again and again
as this case was re-fought
in different forms,
and only the first one was
actually called Ciotti,
as it was fought in different
forms, what they argued
was that because the
state and because
private non-tribal water
users couldn't show proof
that their claims were not
unreasonably interfering
with the planned use, then
that burden could not be met.
And so a new water use
permit could not be issued.
And so this decision had
a few significant impacts.
It gave the tribes, the
CSKT, a significant amount
of bargaining power,
because municipalities
and non-Indian reservations
on the Flathead reservation
couldn't apply to the state for
new or amended beneficial use
permits so long as the tribe's
reserved rights remained
unquantified.
And the potential
negative impact
on the state of having to
litigate each of the claims
separately, to the tribal
[INAUDIBLE] separately,
was [INAUDIBLE].
It's also important to note
because the non-Indian permit
holders were frightened of
not receiving sufficient water
for their own uses or losing
their water rights altogether
because of the possibility
of the tribes having reserved
claims.
And this generated
political panic
among non-Indian municipal
and county politicians
and amongst other
irrigators in the region.
In 1982, the tribes in
anticipation of negotiations
with the Compact
Commission collaborated
with the US Geological Survey
on an extensive drainage
by drainage measurement program
of groundwater, surface water,
stream flow, river flow,
minimum fill levels
of different bodies of water.
And so by the time the
negotiations started in 2000,
the US government
and the tribes were
in possession of an
unprecedented amount of data
about the water that
was up for review.
I got to interview
a long time tribal
attorney who started his
career in the early '80s
and retired last year.
So his career was bookended
basically by this negotiation.
What he said was
that fact finding
was a process of sharing
data with the state
to bring the state up to speed.
And it's something that
I think was interesting
about the negotiations is
that opposition, especially
from legislators over the
course of negotiations,
was often ignorance,
because just the knowledge
was so one sided at the
start of negotiations.
Finally, it's important to
note that the alternative
to negotiations loomed
over the negotiations.
The tribes of the
state if they did not
agree to a compact,
the two sides
would be forced to litigate
each claim separately
in the Water Court.
That would have been very
costly and taken many years.
And it was a valid fear on the
part of the non-tribal water
users that they would
be at risk of losing
their state appropriated water
rights because of the tribe's
earlier priority dates.
Even the tribes recognized that
having to litigate their claims
would be costly and burdensome.
And just to give
you a sense, these
are just the off-reservation
claims that you see here.
The left are 97 rights
that as of 2018, it
changed a little bit
after that, as of 2018,
the tribe was going to
maintain off reservation.
And these are the
rights that the state
thought the tribe had
the ability to adjudicate
if they didn't have a compact.
And so if a compact
wasn't reached,
the tribe could have gone
to court and litigated
upwards of 10,000
different water
claims across Western Montana.
And as a result, there was a
lot of incentive for the state
to come to a settlement that
both quantified the tribe's
rights and also protected
the junior rights
of non-tribal water users
so that this didn't occur
and there wasn't decades of
litigation over these rights.
So in terms of the negotiation
topics, that the body kind
of discussed, there were
on-reservation rights
pertaining to the irrigation
project, on-reservation rights
pertaining to the
irrigation deliveries.
So this is water from
the irrigation project
that has historically been
used by non-tribal water users.
And so their right to continue
to receive that water.
There was water from
the Flathead system,
meaning the Flathead River, its
tributaries, and Flathead Lake.
And then there were a number
of non-consumptive rights.
Off reservation, there were
instream flow rights as well as
state law based
non-irrigation rights,
which I'll talk about
a little more later.
Actually one thing
that I didn't put here
is the other thing
that was obviously
a part of this was
off-reservation rights claimed
by non-tribal users, which is
most off-reservation rights
that were at risk as a result of
this were by non-tribal users.
And somehow I didn't
put that on here.
And then there was
implementation.
And so these were
the discussions.
I'm going to put a kind of
calendar in front of you.
And I don't need you to
read through all of it.
This is the first of two pages.
Because I really want
to call your attention
to a couple of things.
So the first thing
is the start date.
The first negotiation
sessions occurred in 2000.
But in 2001, the state issued--
and this is after all three of
the Ciotti I and II were done
and the Ciotti III was currently
before the Supreme Court.
And despite that,
the state issued
yet another on-reservation
permit during negotiations
despite multiple rulings
by the Supreme Court.
And I think it's
important just because it
chose to accept a
level of distrust
and also the level of skepticism
that the tribe had about
the state's ability
to and willingness
to negotiate forthrightly.
I think it's also important that
the facilitator who was brought
in 2011, Edward
Sheets, I was told,
and I've been trying to
get in touch with him
and I haven't been
able to, but I
was told that
relatively little had
been decided by
the time he began
working on the negotiations.
And he brought order
to the negotiations
and served as an unbiased party
with which both sides could
discuss.
And I think the impact
of him as a neutral party
is really important.
I think also just
the number of years
that passed between
2002 and 2005,
the two sides turned
their attention entirely
to negotiating an
interim agreement
once they realized
how long it would take
to come to a final agreement.
And then because of a
number of political reasons,
they abandoned the
interim agreement.
When the compact failed
in the state legislature
in 2013, because
that's what occurred,
the first compact was agreed to.
It went to the
state legislature.
It failed.
And much of the
opposition at the time
was Republican representatives
expressed some concern
that the compact
didn't sufficiently
protect non-tribal water users.
And some of it was legitimate
concern, though some of it
appears to have been
political grandstanding.
Then the state and the tribes
agreed to a limited reopening.
Two years later when the
legislature meets again,
they pass it.
And then it went
to the US Congress
where it sat for five
years in different forms
with slight amendments
occurring all over the place
until finally it passed as a
part of the COVID-19 stimulus
bill in December.
And just days after that,
the tribe council passed it
and now it's awaiting a
bureaucratic review that is
expected to be simple, routine.
I was told by John
Carter, the former staff
attorney for the tribes,
that one thing that
helped the revised agreement
pass two years later
was extensive dialogue with
a couple of key Republicans
who were willing to learn
more about the agreement
but whose opposition in
2013 faded by 2015 once they
understood the thing better.
So that's I think something that
I will return to at the end,
but just the importance
of that understanding.
So this is where they ended up.
On-reservation rights were
protected in a number of ways.
The tribes agreed to 211
total on-reservation rights.
Really detailed.
I didn't get into
the detail here
in terms of how
it's apportioned,
and where it comes
from, where it goes.
With a priority date
of 1855, they then
agreed to relinquish
the right to call
all other on-reservation rights.
The state agreed to give the
tribes ownership of the--
or to the US ownership and trust
of the tribe of the irrigation
project provided that
the tribe continued
to deliver a certain quantity
of water to non-tribal water
users, non-tribal irrigators
who have historically
used the irrigation project.
And that was a really
contentious part
of the agreement, because a
number of the non-tribal users
wanted the state to
retain ownership.
Then there were a number
of non-consumptive rights.
So one quote-- I'll skip a
little bit, but one quote,
I want to say this is a quote
from a Big Timber rancher named
Lawrence Grossfield who formed
a group to help support the 2015
version of the compact, the
revised version of the compact.
She gave this in 2015.
And she said, oh, he gave it.
Sorry, Lawrence.
"There wasn't much in
the way two years ago
of an educational effort for
the press or legislatures
or anybody.
We're going to be
out and visible
and just trying to spread
accurate information
about the compact and
the whole process."
And two years later after
the first agreement failed,
that educational process
was really important.
Off reservation,
the tribes retained
eight off-reservation instream
flow rights as well as
58 additional rights
to be co-owned
by the state and the tribes
with very detailed parameters.
The tribe has agreed to
relinquish 97%, many thousands
of claims protecting the
non-tribal users across Western
Montana.
And that was hugely important.
I want to point out one thing,
which is that the map I showed
you earlier of the
off-reservation claims,
it said on the map
that there were
97 off-reservation
rights in 2018
that the tribe were getting.
But by the time the
actual agreement
was passed by the US Congress,
that number had dropped to 58.
And that occurred because
Senator Daines of Montana
basically with the tribes
negotiated slight changes
in order to get other
senators on board,
the US Senators on board.
So it's interesting that even
once the agreement had passed,
it was agreed to
by the two sides,
even once the state
legislature had agreed
to it, four years later when
it was with the US Congress,
they were continuing to
negotiate over minor points
so that they could get this
thing passed once and for all
and quantify the tribe's rights.
Implementation.
At the very
beginning, the tribes
wanted a unitary system that
they controlled on reservation.
Over time they came
to an agreement
for a unitary system that
was jointly controlled.
And this was unprecedented
for the state who had never
given up some management to
one of the tribes in the state
and also was a significant
concession by the tribes.
This joint board is currently
being set up with help
from the state commission.
And the state agreed
also to give $50 million
to a number of water measurement
and irrigation efforts.
The unitary system is something
that a lot of the, also again,
the non-tribal irrigators
were very upset about,
because they felt that
they would lose the ability
to negotiate rights, that
they felt they should not
have to go to the tribe for.
I'll leave it at that for now.
A couple of conclusions
that I want to bring up.
One is that divergent knowledge
is an impediment early
on in negotiations.
That water management should
be a joint undertaking
or jointly observed.
I think it's really
interesting that one
of the major impediments
in the first years
was simply the fact that the
state didn't have anything
close to the level
of understanding
of the existing water on the
reservation that the tribes had
and that the US government had.
Second, that
impartial facilitators
are essential and
should be utilized
even before negotiations begin.
That the first
decade wasn't wasted.
Some stuff was decided upon.
But by all accounts, when
Edward Sheets was brought on,
things moved forward
much more smoothly
in a really ordered fashion and
with a lot less chest beating.
And third, so when
politics are bound
to get in the way of an
agreement's approval,
it's better to include
skeptical parties
than to build a wall
around negotiators.
This is a personal thing.
I think that certain state
representatives and senators as
well as some major
irrigators might have been,
if they had been educated
on the negotiations
prior to the document's
public release, it's possible,
I don't know if
this is for certain,
but it's possible that
some of their resistance
could have been mitigated.
And then again,
adaptive, which we've
talked about before
this class, adaptive
governance necessitates
shared control.
Finally, I didn't know
what to do with this.
It's one question I've been
grappling with in the past days
as I've been editing my
doc by my written report.
Which is basically, what
should we make of the fact
that even after the CSKT, after
the tribes have negotiated
with everybody in
good faith they
had to give up additional
rights in order
to get it passed
by the US Congress?
Is there another system,
given the complexity
of the process, another system
that could have been set up
to help create a process
that wouldn't have required
as much legal approval?
Or is that simply a
fact of history and we
need to accept it?
And just it's a question
I'm interested in.
And with that, I will open it
up for comments and questions.
And I know that was a
lot, so thank you all.
DR. GAIN: Thank you, Aron,
for the nice presentation.
So now I would
like to ask Husnain
to make comments and feedback.
AUDIENCE: Very well done,
Aron, with your presentation.
You really picked a very
complicated case study,
because it involves a
lot of stakeholders.
So as it involves a lot of
stakeholders, my first question
would be, how do you think
that all stakeholders came
into one page and
why do you think
this treaty took so much
time to finally conclude?
Because it involved
a lot of litigation.
What was the things
which were not going
in the right direction before?
And what was the thing which
happened this time to make it
in the right direction?
STUDENT PRESENTER: In terms
of why it took so long,
there are a couple of things.
When the Water Commission
was created, when the Compact
Commission was created
in the late '70s,
they had about a little
over a dozen agreements
to negotiate with the
federal government
and with the state's tribes.
And they purposefully
did all of the others
and then did the
Flathead reservation one
because the Flathead reservation
was the most complicated.
And I think that actually
wasn't a good thing.
I think that there was a
lot of study and animosity
and kind of divergence
that occurred
in those intervening decades.
In part, I think,
because the tribes
saw what was coming out
of these other agreements
and immediately began
formulating alternate things,
alternate ideas,
because they didn't
like what the other
agreements were saying.
And so a lot more could have
been done earlier, I think,
if discussions had started in
the early '80s, for example,
or the mid '80s.
I think the other things
that impeded the timeline
first is that partially
because of that,
the tribes came into
the negotiations
with a lot of
preconceived notions
about what the final
agreement should look like.
And there were a
lot of news reports,
for example, after their first
formal negotiation session.
All of these things
that the tribe said
that they wanted in
the final agreement
that the states immediately
threw up their hands
and said, absolutely not.
And negotiations actually shut
down for a year at that point.
And so if those
conversations could
have started in the '80s when
the tribes were beginning
their process of studying
the water quantity, the water
quality, and if the questions
regarding the implementation
could have been ongoing,
I think a lot of anger
could have been mitigated.
So a part of it was
just there was so much
confrontation going into
the agreement and very
little trust.
And the other thing
I think took a lot--
the second thing
I want to say is
that I think that the
role of the negotiator
was really important.
Without the negotiator, a lot
of the opportunity for building
trust didn't occur.
And they became venting
sessions, the negotiations,
and it wasn't always
a productive thing.
So that's the question.
In terms of what
took so long, I think
the negotiator helped a lot.
And then I think
eventually having--
I mean, and this is where
I think the water diplomacy
framework does come
to bear significantly,
which is that I think once the
two sides did have a shared
understanding of the
quantity of water and all
the different locations and
of the various legal arguments
of the potential uses,
once there was that shared
understanding, it was a lot
easier to come to agreements,
because they understood
from what point
they were compromising from.
Whereas the tribes went into it
with a lot more understanding
and would put up a very
hard wall to begin with.
And so having that
shared understanding
was really important.
Sorry, I think I rambled
on a little bit there,
but I hope I got
to your questions.
DR. GAIN: So
Husnain, do you have
further a specific question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, one more.
Yeah.
It is related to the water
diplomacy win-win framework.
How do you think both
parties agreed on this?
On a win-win side, for
example, I read somewhere,
I was doing some
research on it yesterday,
and I read that the tribes were
allocated the national bison
range, which I think somehow
was an attractive thing for them
for agreeing to this treaty.
There's a secondary note
with this question is,
you mentioned in
one of your slides
that the number of non-tribes
is more than the actual tribal
people.
So given the--
I just want to
understand from you
what is the percentage
of tribal people there
and non-tribal people.
And how do you think that
balances or evens out
the whole treaty and things
in the Montana region?
STUDENT PRESENTER:
So just to clarify,
the national bison range is
on the Flathead reservation.
So the tribes were given
rights over the management
of that range.
But it was already
on the reservation.
It wasn't something
off reservation
that they were fighting over.
It was on reservation land that
was under the legal authority
of the tribes but managed in
trust by the federal government
until this occurred.
In terms of the--
sorry, what was
your question about the
numbers of non-tribal members?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I wanted to know that
in this whole Montana
region in which the
treaty is enforced,
what is the percentage
of the tribal
people are there and
the non-tribal people?
How much benefit are they going
to get, the non-tribal people?
STUDENT PRESENTER:
So I can't remember
the population of the tribe.
I don't remember right now.
I believe I believe it's
about 8,000 and about 60%
of the members live
on the reservation.
So I believe it's--
I don't know.
The tribal members,
maybe it's 5,000.
I can't remember exactly right
now how many tribal members
live on the reservation.
It's a few times that
in non-tribal members.
I'm not sure of
the exact numbers,
again, of non-tribal members
who live on-reservation
but it's a few times that.
The town of Polson,
which is the biggest
town on the reservation, has
a population of about three
and a half thousand.
There are many
other small towns.
So those rights, the tribes
were given-- this agreement
quantified, just
to clarify, maybe
I didn't make this clear before,
this agreement quantified
the tribe's rights
on the reservation.
But then there's
still other water.
So that other water then,
because the tribe's rights
are quantified, can now be
claimed by non-tribal users
on the reservation,
if that makes sense.
With regards to the
irrigation project,
the irrigation project
included a number of delivery .
schedules and those delivery
schedules were specifically
to provide water to
non-tribal irrigators who have
historically used that water.
And there was a lot of
disagreement about that.
Those irrigators,
many of them argue
that the amount of water
they would be allocated
was insufficient
and they were going
to have to move their lands.
And the state of Montana
agreed to actually support them
by helping to invest in drip
agriculture and other things.
But it will protect
over the long term
their rights, the non-tribal
rights on the reservation.
But the one limitation is that
the tribal rights, which are
quantified, now have priority.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: I
took Husnain's question
to refer to proportionality.
If you look at the
overall benefits that
are allocated to the federal
government, the state
government, the tribe,
and non-tribal members
living on the reservation,
does the final agreement
reflect some kind of
proportionality, equal
proportion of gain?
However measured, did
everybody come out
roughly the same relative
to the gains that they got?
Not in terms of how
many people, but just
in terms of these
different categories.
STUDENT PRESENTER: Yeah.
That's a good question.
So in terms of number
of people, I don't know.
In terms of the categories,
the non-irrigators
on the reservation, yes.
So non-irrigators meaning not
the irrigation project users.
The non-irrigators
definitely did.
The municipalities are going to
have sufficient water to grow.
Homeowners and developers
can build again
for both reservation and
non-reservation and non-tribal
members.
There's a significant
amount of enough water
and now enough legal clarity
that that was a gain in itself.
The group off
reservation as well,
I think that a lot of the
off-reservation, definitely
the non-tribal members of
the citizens of the state
gained a lot because
the tribe event gave up
a lot of their claims.
The one area where I think
there's still disagreement on
and I don't have a--
I think that it's still
very controversial
and it will be throughout
implementation--
is on-reservation irrigators
I think are one group that's
still a number of whom still
feel like they did not have
sufficient-- they did not
gain sufficient protection
as a result of the negotiations.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: Good.
That's a good answer.
Thank you.
DR. GAIN: Anselmo, do you have
any feedback or a question
to Aron?
AUDIENCE: Yes, I
will be very quickly.
First, Aron, congratulations
for your case.
Very well done.
Very well.
It's a complex case study.
I just want to highlight
some points here.
I appreciate the
historic context
that you gave from
1855 into 2000.
Also I liked to learn a lot
about the "first in time,
first in right" that you
mentioned before that 1973.
And you mentioned
that the facilitator
arrived in the
negotiation only in 2011.
But even with the
facilitator, it took 9 years
to reach the agreement.
STUDENT PRESENTER:
So to clarify,
it actually took-- so the
facilitator arrived in 2011.
They reached their
first agreement in 2013.
So that was when they
reached the agreement.
Then as a result, the result of
the state legislature voting it
down, they renegotiated
the agreement in 2015.
And at that point, it was
just sitting in Congress.
So they weren't
negotiating anymore.
There were some minor
things that were changed,
and the facilitator is
actually still involved.
But it actually only
took two years with him
to reach that agreement.
AUDIENCE: Oh, two years.
Oh, great.
Aron, you don't
have to do it here,
because I know Gemma has
to present the Columbia
presentation, but if you can
describe more in your paper
the negotiation process
with the Compact Commission,
I like a lot the slide you
post there with the 90 members.
And if you can compare
with the water managed
board, that's only having
five members, right?
Six members, but
only five can vote.
It's only-- I really appreciate.
Congratulations.
STUDENT PRESENTER: Thank you.
Trying to understand
the negotiation process
has been really tricky.
I've read and I've heard
that there are transcripts
of the negotiations out
there, but I've actually
called around.
I've called the DRC and
a number of other people
who would probably
do them, and I've
emailed people who mentioned
them, who have cited them,
and I can't find them.
I have a lot of the,
what's it called,
the topic lists, but
not the-- but not
the transcripts themselves,
which is a disappointment.
DR. GAIN: So any other
question or comments
from Flora or Gemma?
OK.
STUDENT PRESENTER:
Thank you all.
Appreciate your feedback.
DR. GAIN: Yes.
Maybe before Larry, I would
like to ask one thing.
So how does national
politics played a role?
Because I learned
that the corporation--
the state legislator,
specifically
the Republican
legislator, is not
in favor of this
water right issue.
And there is some issue
within the Republican
and there are some conflicts.
So how does it play a
role in the negotiation
process in this treaty?
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: I defy
anybody to explain that.
Anybody.
I don't care who they are.
Because there's what the
system is designed to do
and there's what the political
system actually does.
And what it actually
does is a function
of who has the
majority and who's
in leadership in the
executive branch.
And it doesn't matter what
it says on paper about what
is a state's right, what
is a national government's
right, what is executive,
what is legislative.
Doesn't matter.
It all changes
every time there's
a shift in power
and relationships.
So there is no way to answer
the question about what
is this crazy intergovernmental
system we have supposed to do
relative to Indian rights.
Because you then also
have the court entering.
We have these three branches.
And the Supreme Court
got involved in this case
at one stage, as
you heard from Aron.
And you have the
state legislature
and you have the federal
government legislature,
the Congress.
But you also have the agencies.
And the agencies
have responsibilities
for the tribes, the
Interior Department.
It is an insanely
complicated system,
and it's very hard
to know what's
going on even when
it's happening,
because it's not transparent.
And people make all kinds of
private deals and other issues
get traded off against the
issue you're interested in.
And you don't even
know that that's why
somebody voted a certain way.
They didn't care
about the issue,
but they got something
from somebody else
for something else.
So unraveling all
of that, I mean,
I think Aron did a wonderful
job, as best you can do,
of at least getting a timeline
and looking at the outcomes.
But the process?
I mean, even with
the transcript,
it's indecipherable.
And everything related to Native
Americans in the United States
doesn't go the way the
law says it's supposed to.
Every treaty has been broken,
continues to be broken.
Every promise, everything that
the US government promised
and committed to, none
of it's been upheld.
And so yeah, I can point
to what the system says.
And somebody can hold up a
treaty and say, look here.
I'm guaranteed certain rights.
Yeah, well, try to
get it enforced.
So it's the complexity of the
US intergovernmental system
and the extent to which
it's really not transparent,
what's happening, make
it impossible to answer
your question.
DR. GAIN: Thanks.
So maybe for the final
paper, I would like to ask,
because this is one of the
treaty that is successful
recently in terms
of water treaty.
So maybe you can share very
specific lessons learned
from the negotiation process.
I think that would be
much more helpful in terms
of water diplomacy aspect.
I think as this is very new kind
of treaty that is successful
and how the process
works and what
are the general lesson learned.
I think that would be much
more interesting things.
PROFESSOR SUSSKIND: I really
liked the four concluding
points that you had.
I think those were very strong.
And as long as in the text
you will elaborate on them
slightly, but as four
concluding points
in terms of what can be
learned from this case,
I think they're terrific.
STUDENT PRESENTER: Thank you.